we have kevin van oort here who is the
reviewer for a game called evolve mm-hmm
which came out today on video game
systems sure multitude of including pc
for installation for just one wonderful
take that past gen Chris you've played a
bunch of it as well I sure have and
we've had a bunch of shots here in the
office yeah that's at that game and
games captured a lot of us indeed and
it's also captured the attention of our
viewers and readers and like we did a
couple of Mexico we're gonna have a new
section asked the reviewer or some other
questions I'll be honest some of these
aren't questions so much as they are
statements that's unusual because our
readers usually are not are short of
opinion usually they have very little to
say these are mostly statements which
have been mostly edited by myself some
have not take take taken out the the
absent yet the season sometimes one I
rearranged one remain free range really
don't want to read one yeah alright this
one's from cryo tech he says I'm very
skeptical priorities a game yes the
creative CryEngine I'm very skeptical
about this game it seems like the kind
of game that'll get really boring really
quickly and there's a second question
which ties into the same sort of thing
about length which is from Pierce
sparrow played the beta and not for me
too repetitive I feel find arena
shooters okay but the lack of
progression already tells me that I
probably get bored of it same thing
happened with titanfall was fun for a
while but doing the same thing over and
over again gets boring so what you guys
think about that though the repetition
involved involved you know I think you
know I'm gonna you know come right up
and say one of the hardest things to
gauge when your critic is longevity
there's it's so it's probably the
hardest thing to do from an evaluation
standpoint is say is this game gonna be
popular in 20 years or 20 years is this
too because people be playing ball over
20 years lenovo seriously like like in
two weeks in four weeks in six weeks
into months and so on like our people
still gonna play it is not easily the
hardest thing to figure out but i can
use my own like i can only use my own
reaction to the game as a
gage arm and Chris and I've talked about
titanfall on this for example and my
titanfall love wore out fast on the
other hand i pry put in I've put in a
good 30 plus hours maybe 35 hours now
and evolve I haven't tired of it yet but
I think this is it really is one of
those not one size fits all kind of
things because I come from a time I'm
old and I come from a time when unreal
tournament 2004 and half life to death
match and these were these were the fit
well I'm earlier than that the unreal
unreal unreal tournament NCS when all
those things in enemy territory and
things like that these are the things I
was never really a counter-strike guy
but you get you get the idea like
progression really wasn't a thing for me
and it in it you know I don't think
evolve for all of its menus and all the
things you unlock and stuff it actually
feels pretty much like a standard arena
shooter in that sense to me like I don't
really come for the progression in this
sense unlike something like destiny
which is really built around that idea
but for this it really is the
entertainment value it's the freshness
of one match over the next down down to
the pure gameplay of it and for that
this keeps me invested match after match
because there are so many variables that
seem small on paper but can actually
very much change the course of the
gameplay and so for me like the
progression is not really much of a
thing because I'm more I'm more just
focused on the core gameplay which which
keeps me very involved over and over but
if you need that progression is why
don't not be free yeah I mean
progression is one way that shooters
keep people invested and that certainly
does isn't really where evolve is going
to shine one of the ways that I stay
invested in the shooter is being able to
play it in different roles so that's why
I really a battlefield series because
you can play different classes and you
are like actually doing subsidy
different substance into lead if you're
doing different stuff you know you're
playing the medic you're playing the
sniper here we're getting in vehicles
like you are experiencing that battle
which is basically the same battle every
time right in different ways and so
it's different for you and that's where
I think the classes of Hunter really
help at least have helped me because
even if you're playing medic three
matches in a row if you play the three
different medics you're playing a
significantly different experience
because you have to focus on different
bits of kit etc beyond that though is
the fact that this like the asymmetry of
evolved because I mean if you're a
hunter it's a shooter but if you're the
monster yeah it's not it's not a shooter
it's like I it's a beat'em up sometimes
I mean it's like I don't I was like a
hundred scribers in like the third
person action game or something but
you're you know you're faced with these
or human players instead of AI well you
can also play AI but I because you can
play both sides of the coin I'll find if
I play a bunch of Hunter and I flip it
to monster it's I mean it's a different
game it feels very different and your
experience of it changes I'm going to
get into a couple more questions here
and dot to the ferry one thanks for that
if you don't hey if you don't have
friends this game isn't fun it's more
like a six out of ten without friends
how many points did you give this game
for friend life is a six out of ten
without it really i mean i don't know
this may not be a surprise considering
turtle rock also made left for dead yes
but left for dead is also better with
people you know then with strangers and
I don't think evolves any differently I
pointed that out in the review I try to
make sure that it was you know hey this
is the kind of thing that's better with
friends and with strangers the good news
though is is that strangers usually
pretty quick to pick up on what they
need to do the game like you get caught
alone in your you're punished you can't
really be a lone ranger in this game if
you want that play on the monster arm so
yeah you can you can find yourself with
some some doodads get here and there's a
risk anytime you play a team based game
is you're going to get a doozy on your
team and they're gonna suck and they're
gonna ruin that match for you but I
think what evolved does that's
interesting to me is a lot of people are
averse to being on a headset with people
they don't know yes sure fine right
there would ya I I think but then they
have games like battlefield where you
have contextual things where you can be
like need a medic Oh
in my vehicle but like people don't
really listen to that unless they're
super good and if they're super good
you're probably not having trouble with
that stuff anyways what evolved has is
you click the stick to put a waypoint on
the map and it literally makes a dot and
a front sound so its base with you being
like and like that like that is kind of
like it actually is it's a digital
equivalent of grunting you know but it's
it's sort of Orient's your team in the
right direction it sort of is like hey
pay attention to me figure out I need
something you know the list of things
that could it could be like go over here
watch out for that I'm putting it on
myself on the ground because I need
healing and you're totally blowing it
medic like right yeah it's kinda it's
kind of a good little stop it's good
little uh you know connection between
people it does it does just enough yes
it's just enough yeah and the bots help
because when you play like I actually
really like if I'm not in the mood for
people and I'm often not in the mood for
people uh then then actually I i really
like jumping into like an evacuation and
playing with the AI I mean they have
their their little problems you know but
overall I'm actually surprised given the
the the asymmetry of evolve that the AI
actually does a fairly good job of
keeping up good enough that I'm
entertained if I want to play an
evacuation which takes you know me 45
minutes to an hour if you want to play
an evacuation campaign and then just
then just go to bed I do with the AI and
I'm fine if I'm not in the mood for
Maroons I think were the last question I
want to get to and this is something
that came up a lot m2k when they were
talking about this game like we talked
about it a couple of weeks ago on the
lobby about how they kind of muddled see
how you buy this game thing and the idea
of like what is in evolve and the value
there in has definitely come into
question with the amount of DLC that's
available right at the gate so donuts 82
says I'm not feeling it our way still a
definitive or game of the year edition
comes out so I get all the dlc and the
game then I'll wait till it drops to
like 30 40 bucks and I'll consider
buying it do you think that it's worth
sixty dollars as it is now yeah I do um
this is this is a thing too that's this
really interesting and talked a lot
about people online to people online
about this
I think 2k really hurt themselves with
the way they marketed the game with the
way they focused so much on dealsea with
the way everybody knew that there was
going to be piecemeal DLC for this game
and it was still gonna cost you 60 bucks
and it would I think it's even a bigger
deal for this game because 2k made such
a big deal out of that tried to spin it
as a positive but of course we don't
usually see it that way a positive
option that you think was them have
marketing for being like crap our games
delayed we have to talk about running in
the next few months we got the niazi
stuff yeah i mean but the way I look at
things is you know it's funny because
usually I try to avoid as much
pre-release coverage of games as
possible you can always do that when you
work in the industry you certainly can't
do that when you're a small staff and
have to do events and stuff but
typically i try to avoid preview
coverage bioware's burnt me too many
times in the past by spoiling stuff yes
so but in but in this case I'm kind of
glad I did because I think a lot of what
colors people's pain duvall before they
even play it is this whole DLC business
I didn't really know all I know is I got
the vanilla game I started playing it I
I've played 35 hours of it and I never
felt like it was missing something and
so maybe I'm lucky because I wasn't
really paying close attention to what
was going to come and what I could buy
now when I looked at you know mostly
it's just cosmetic stuff right yeah but
there will be hunters and motion oh yeah
have the fundamental parts about it
doesn't don't you want more stuff so
don't you get for your game don't you
want more stuff maybe I wanted it in the
game in the first so that I think having
that sitting on the right question right
there is when you're going to buy the
game like if there's talk about DLC that
gives the impression that you're not
getting a hundred percent of the yeah
but that is like a false like that's you
mate look you gotta understand what
assumptions you're making when you
decide that like okay I'm deciding that
all of the development teams efforts in
this period of time leading up to
release should cost me sixty dollars
that should be all efforts for here yeah
but like well that's not the reality
because games like you've all have to go
gold like at eight week eight weeks
beforehand but oh we have today one
patches so maybe they're working on the
patch but then like where do you draw
the line then for
like okay now the developers efforts
towards something that's planned to
release in three months that's not part
of the game that's part of adding
content to the game because we also like
at content added I guess I don't trust
it like that is always the case like I
always think that no matter what happens
in big business there's always some sort
of suit that's like all right you know
what just like section off this part of
the team and they're gonna be our DLC
strategy because we want to make sure
we're getting Bank off this six months 9
months 12 months down the road and
people i think i like wary of that to
the point so that when they were so
upfront about yo this is the game also
if you're like one of those what they
call them whales you want to pick up the
big thing for like a hundred dollars
there's that one there by the way we're
gonna charge you for this other little
bit you know i'm so burnt about there
not being free maps for every first
person shooter like that's how we grew
up playing first-person games but I'd
like game modes it still stings so bad
you gotta realize that that's like me
there that is you know from your own
experience that is kind of a cynical
approach and you've hurt you've earned
it a little bit because of the history
of games that you're used to but the
market that were in these days if you
put in the budget to make a huge game
like this and like that's a huge risk
because it's maybe not going to sell its
maybe gonna get pirated you know they're
like big publishers we've seen go down
and so if you have a way to extend what
kind of money you can make from that
game to extend the life of that game so
that you're not making an evolved to
immediately in bankrolling that huge
project your instead making installments
of DLC for all that you have like tease
that out I think that's where we're at
in terms of the strategy and yeah like
that kind of mental shift is is really
tough to kind of remain optimistic about
especially when they're asking you for
15 more dollars for like four hunters
yeah it's weird for all I hey deal see
anyway yeah so I mean over you know deal
I'm just distrustful of DLC as a rule
yeah on what was interesting to me with
evolve was to see this game being
targeted a lot more I think bye bye just
normal folks arm over other other other
certain games the strike me is doing the
same thing like Mike my god have you
seen what like fighting games do for
example for the most part like street
fighter cross tekken and and stuff like
that like there there lots of reasons to
be
I think the reason evolve really hit
that radars because of how much
attention the publisher itself yeah
maybe they do it yeah maybe they do not
drop a little bit too much but also one
little tidbit before we wrap it up all
the maps will be free yes for we look
for it which is good it's just something
that neither battlefield or call of duty
of managed to do ya at the review is up
on gamespot com it is funny super
reductive and give it a score no today
it'sit's s I think that I think that
game is legitimately great and let's I'm
hoping that in three months and six
months and so on that where people are
still playing and having a really good
time awesome we're going to talk about
review scores in just a little bit but
first of all we're going to shoot it off
for a second a few of any comments about
that by all means put them underneath
this video let us know what you think
about evolve itself and a better review
as well
you